♪ ♪
>> Jesse: CNN FEELING THE HEAT
AFTER ONE OF THEIR ANCHORMAN
MOCKED TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
HERE IS CNN’S ATTEMPT TO CLEAN
IT UP.
>> I DON’T BELIEVE IN BELITTLING
PEOPLE.
BELITTLING ANYONE FOR WHO THEY
ARE, WHAT THEY BELIEVE, AND
WHERE THEY’RE FROM HERE DURING
AN INTERVIEW ON SATURDAY NIGHT,
ONE OF MY GUESTS SAID SOMETHING
THAT MADE ME LAUGH AND IN THE
MOMENT, I FOUND THAT JOKE
HUMOROUS.
I DIDN’T CATCH EVERYTHING THAT
WAS SAID.
JUST TO MAKE THIS PERFECTLY
CLEAR, I WAS LAUGHING AT THE
JOKE, AND NOT AT ANY GROUP OF
PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: THAT SEMIAPOLOGY HAS
COME TO LITTLE, TOO LATE.
THE RNC ALREADY LAUNCHING A
BRUTAL ADD BASED OFF THE SEGMENT
SEGMENT.
>> YOU COULD PUT HALF OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS INTO WHAT I CALL THE
BASKET OF DEPLORABLES.
>> THAT IS PARTLY THEM PLAYING
TO THEIR BASE.
>> ANYONE SUPPORTING THIS
PRESIDENT IS, AT BEST, LOOKING
THE OTHER WAY.
SPEAK OF THE CREDULOUS BOOMER
RUBE DEMO THAT BACKS THE DONALD
THAT WANTS TO THINK THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS THE SMART ONE,
AND Y’ALL ELITISTS ARE DOWN.
>> Jesse: WE PREDICTED THAT
THE OTHER DAY THAT THERE WAS
GOING TO BE AN ADD ON THAT AND
THERE YOU HAVE.
DO YOU DON LEMONS APOLOGY,
SAYING, I WAS ONLY LAUGHING AT
THAT INITIAL JOKE.
YOU NEXT TO A PICTURE OF A CRANE
AND NOT ALL THE OTHER --
’S BEFORE FIRST OF ALL, THE JOKE
WAS ABOUT HOW DUMB TRUMP
SUPPORTERS ARE, SO THAT IS WHAT
HE WAS LAUGHING AT.
THIS IS CNN’S PROBLEM.
THEY NEVER OWNED THAT THEY ARE
BIASED AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT
WHAT HE WAS LAUGHING AT WAS NOT
JUST BIAS, IT WAS VERY BIGOTED.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF YOU ON YOUR
SHOW HOW TO SEGMENT AND PEOPLE
WERE LAUGHING AND MAKING THOSE
KINDS OF COMMENTS ABOUT THE WAY
PEOPLE SPEAK, HOW DUMB THEY ARE
AND GOING AFTER THE SAME --
>> Jesse: NEVER HAPPENED ON
THIS PROGRAM.
>> Katie: BUT GOING AFTER VERY
SPECIFIC KINDS OF PEOPLE, VERY
SPECIFIC DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS, THE
WAY THEY TALK, HOW EDUCATED THEY
ARE, HOW UNEDUCATED THEY ARE,
AND THAT THEY ARE STUPID AND
THAT IS WHY THEY SUPPORT A
CERTAIN PRESIDENT.
THAT IS BIGOTRY AND THE STANDARD
IS DOUBLE.
AND CNN ACTS LIKE THEY ARE
OBJECTIVE AND UNLIMITED IS
PROVING THEY ARE NOT.
>> Jesse: WOULD YOU CONSIDER
THAT BIGOTRY?
>> Juan: NO, IT WAS NOT
DIRECTED IN TERMS OF ANYONE’S
RACE, ETHNICITY OR RELIGION.
>> Katie: YES IT WAS.
IT DEFINITELY WAS.
>> Juan: OH, I DON’T THINK SO.
IT WAS DIRECTED AT TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
>> Jesse: BUT THE SOUTHERN
TWANG.
>> Juan: YOU CAN GO ON WITH
THE GRIEVANCE, I GET THE POINT.
THAT IS WHY THE AD EXISTS,
BECAUSE IT REALLY DOES PLAY TO
THE WHOLE NOTION OF, WE POOR
CONSERVATIVES, WE TRUMP VOTERS,
WE ARE BEAT UP.
>> Greg: THAT AS EVIDENCE.
>> Juan: I DON’T THINK THAT AS
EVIDENCE.
NUMBER ONE, I DO THINK DON LEMON
IS A SPIN GUY.
I THINK HE SHOULD OWN IT AND
SAY, THIS IS WHAT I THINK.
BUT YOUR .., I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDES, HAVE PROBLEMS
WITH TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
UNVARNISHED, UNWAVERING SUPPORT
FOR A GUY WHO IS OFF-PUTTING AND
DIVISIVE.
>> Katie: BECAUSE THEY TALK
LIKE THAT ABOUT >> Katie:
SUPPORTERS AND DON’T MAKE AN
EFFORT TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH PEOPLE
OUTSIDE.
HE’S NOT A STOMACH ATTACKING
TRUMP,
HE’S ATTACKING THE PEOPLE WHO
VOTE FOR THEM.
>> Juan: I THINK THAT IS
PRETTY IRONIC BECAUSE BOY DO I
SEE REPUBLICANS MOCKING LIBS.
>> Jesse: IT HAPPENS ON BOTH
SIDES BUT THERE ARE REPUBLICANS
CONFUSED ON WHY OBAMA VOTERS DO
NOT SEE ALL THE THINGS YOU ARE
SHOWING THEM ABOUT HIS POLICIES
OR BEHAVIOR OR WHATEVER.
BOTH SIDES HAVE AN ADORING LOVE
FOR WHOEVER THE PRESIDENT IS AT
THE TIME.
>> Greg: I’M JUST WONDERING
WHERE THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER IS ON THIS BECAUSE
THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED HATE.
I DISAGREE WITH YOU ON, IS THIS
BIGOTRY OR NOT BIGOTRY, IT’S
ACTUALLY CLASSISM, RIGHT?
THEY ARE DEMEANING AN ENTIRE
CLASS BUT THEY ARE USING A
STEREOTYPICAL ACCENT WHEN THEY
ARE DEMEANING THE CLASS, WHICH
IS A FORM OF BIGOTRY.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT WHITE
REDNECKS.
THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE BASICALLY
DOING.
THAT IS WHY THEY LAUGHED.
>> Juan: RICK WILSON IS A
REPUBLICAN, BY THE WAY.
BUT THERE ARE BLACK PEOPLE WHO
SPEAK LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT, MAYBE
THAT IS WHERE CNN TOOK THE
STEREOTYPE FROM AND APPLIED IT
TO THE WHITES.
MAYBE THEY JUST PUSHED IT OVER
HERE.
THAT COULD BE IT.
LOOK, THEY CAN’T RECONCILE THEIR
FEELINGS WITH THE WORLD OUTSIDE.
THE WORLD OUTSIDE HAS LEFT THEM
BEHIND AND THAT IS WHY THEY ARE
HAVING A PROBLEM PIER THE RICK
WILSONS OF THE WORLD, NOW THEY
ARE STUCK IN THIS FEEDBACK LOOP
WHERE ALL THEY CAN DO IS GO
ON
CNN AND PUT OUT.
THEY PUT OUT, THEY INVITE YOU
BACK.
THAT IS ALL THAT WAS.
LEMON KIND OF HUNG HIM OUT TO
DRY THERE BUT I DON’T LOOK DOWN
ON THEM BECAUSE I WAS THEM.
I WAS THEM.
I WAS IN NEVER-TRUMPER, THEN
WHEN HE WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT I
DECIDED TO GIVE HIM A CHANCE,
FOCUS ON THE MEASURABLE RESULTS
AND NOT THE TWEETS, AND HE HAS
IMPRESSED ME.
I CHANGED MY TUNE.
AND I THINK THE PROBLEM IS, THEY
CAN’T DO THAT.
THEY ARE STUCK IN THEIR PRISON.
>> Jesse: I ACTUALLY MADE A
SIMILAR POINT, THIS UKRAINE
THING.
YOU CAN GO ON THE STREET AND ASK
ANYONE WHERE UKRAINE IS, TELL ME
ABOUT UKRAINE.
I ACTUALLY DID THAT, AND NO ONE
REALLY KNEW MUCH ABOUT UKRAINE,
AND THEY DIDN’T REALLY
UNDERSTAND THE CONTROVERSY.
AND THAT IS NOT DEMEANING THE
INTELLIGENCE OF PEOPLE.
THAT IS JUST SAYING IT DOESN’T
REALLY RISE TO THE LEVEL OF
SOMETHING THAT THEY CARE ABOUT
EMOTIONALLY AS AN AMERICAN.
>> Dana: IT REMINDS ME OF IN
THE 2000 ELECTION, ONE OF THE
REPORTERS, JUAN, YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER, ASKED GEORGE W. BUSH
TO NAME PRESIDENT OF SLOVENIA
AND OTHERS.
AND THE WHOLE NARRATIVE WAS,
THIS GUY IS SO DUMB THAT HE
DOESN’T KNOW WHO THE PRESIDENT
OF SLOVENIA IS, AND I CAN’T
REMEMBER THE OTHER ONES.
IT JUST REMINDS ME OF THAT.
UNNECESSARY.
I DON’T LOVE THE IDEA, WE COULD
BE AN AD, RIGHT?
THEY COULD TAKE CLIPS FROM US.
BECAUSE EVERYTHING WILL BE FAIR
GAME.
>> Katie: USING OUR SHOW WAS A
BAD EXAMPLE.
>> Greg: I THINK I WAS IN AN
ELIZABETH WARREN AD.
WE’VE BEEN IN ADS.
>> Katie: I WAS IN A
JERRY NADLER FUND-RAISING EMAIL.
>> Greg: OH, WOW, THAT IS A
GREAT BRAG.
>> Katie: YEAH, I DON’T KNOW